[Música]
quando foi a última vez que vocês
pediram uma recomendação de livro para
um amigo quando foi a última vez que
vocês recomendar um livro para alguém ou
quando foi a última vez que vocês
comentaram sobre um livro que estavam
lendo alguns colegas de trabalho por
exemplo
eu tenho certeza que a grande maioria
das pessoas aqui deve ter respondido não
sei
não lembro o faz tempo é só ver o
resultado da última pesquisa feita pelo
ibope em 2016 chamada retrato da
literatura no brasil e revelou que 44%
dos brasileiros não podem ser
considerados leitores isto é 44% dos
brasileiros não leram um inteiro ou em
parte sun um livro nos últimos três
meses
isso é muita gente são quase 100 milhões
de pessoas e um número também não
melhora muito quando a gente fala desses
brasileiros que podem ser considerados
leitores
isso porque a média de livros lidos é de
apenas 2,4 ao ano
eu confesso que se vocês tivessem feito
essa mesma pergunta pra mim há três ou
quatro anos eu teria respondido não
lembro não lembro quando foi a última
vez que eu recomendei um livro para
alguém isso mesmo considerando que eu
era uma criança um jovem que gostava de
ler e que sempre tinha um livro na
cabeceira
mas por que será que essa é a realidade
a resposta é simples a leitura não faz
parte do nosso dia a dia
ela não está na nossa rotina ela não tá
na roda de conversa com os amigos
não tá na mesa de almoço com a família
no domingo não está nos grupos e o
desapegue ninguém fala do próximo livro
que vai ler ou um autor que é um prémio
literário hoje o lançamento de um livro
da mesma forma que a gente fala da
próxima temporada de game of thrones
isso eu digo por experiência própria
mas então por que será que isso acontece
a verdade
é que assim como eu há 34 anos que não
falava sobre leitura que será que mudou
na minha vida pra que em tão pouco tempo
estou aqui hoje ter sido convidado para
compartilhar com vocês
justamente a minha experiência sobre os
livros
vocês podem até pensar a nesse meio
tempo resolveu fazer um curso de letras
ou foi trabalhar no mercado editorial ou
foi fazer um ano sabático pela ásia
lendo livros têm uma idéia na verdade
não é essa
eu sou um advogado trabalha em um
escritório tem uma rotina bem corrida eu
faço academia sair com meus amigos tenho
namorada e principalmente eu não tenho
qualquer qualquer formação no âmbito da
literatura não estou formado em letras
não eu sou leitor comum como a maioria
de vocês aqui isso que eu quero que
vocês saibam eu sou leitor comum
na verdade as coisas começaram a mudar
quando eu descobri a existência de
perfis literários nas redes sociais
isso mesmo universo paralelo que eu não
tinha noção
são pessoas que estão nas redes sociais
para falar sobre livros e até no começo
eu comecei a seguir superfície mas eu
achei que não ia ficar seguindo por
muito tempo até porque essas pessoas
inclusive têm nomes book tuber seu
bookrunners falavam sobre livros que
estavam muito distante dos livros que eu
tô acostumado a ler eu nunca fui aquele
leitor de que sabia o quê e alê
eu recolhi então a lista de mais
vendidos
achando que lá por serem os mais
estariam os melhores livros se é que a
gente pode falar melhor ou pior livro eu
também nasci numa família onde a vida
dos leitores
eu não ia clássicos porque eu tinha medo
que seriam difíceis ou estejam
relacionados a alguma coisa antiga e
sempre ligados àquela obrigação do
vestibular
hoje quando eu vejo esses meus
pensamentos de três ou quatro anos
eu percebi que tinha verdadeiros
conceitos literários sim mas vai
acompanhar diariamente esses perfis
literários que começou a despertar em
mim uma vontade de ler o diferente e
sair da minha zona de conforto
e foi aí que eu dei uma chance as linhas
os meus preconceitos começaram a ser aos
poucos desmistificados então comecei com
um livro escrito por um autor
contemporâneo nascido em angola
depois eu fui para o clássico russo
então temido dostoievski e aí eu escolhi
uma coletânea de contos de uma das mais
incríveis leitor autoras brasileiras e
já fagundes telles
eu vi que esse caminho não tinha volta o
mais legal era perceber que apesar de
viver no meio em que tão pouco se fala
sobre livro eu tinha descoberto um lugar
onde pudesse compartilhar as
experiências e usar como um guia para as
próximas leituras e aos poucos vão
surgindo a idéia de passar isso para
frente se eu o leitor comum tinha tido
uma experiência muito boa com o clássico
russo por exemplo por que as outras
pessoas também não podiam
eu não tenho qualquer informação
literário então é verdade eu quero o meu
perfil literário e foi em maio de 2017
que com 24 anos eu creio buxter e só
vocês terem uma idéia do quanto esse
assunto não era presente no dia a dia
tive até medo de como essa novidade é
recebida pelas pessoas que estavam à
minha volta
no começo eu deixe de bloquear todo
mundo que eu conhecia
sim ninguém sabia do boxster eu era
anônimo do que meus pais e minhas irmãs
meus amigos meu colega de trabalho todo
mundo
- a minha namorada que tinha ajudado a
fazer também ficam sou louco de mente
uma coisa pra ela e aí
aos poucos eu também não achei que ia
virar alguma coisa grande eu acho que a
escala eu no máximo 100 seguidores
falando sobre livros que está demais
porque te encontrar o meu espaço
mas aos poucos em algumas semanas alguns
meses dos 100 seguidores eu partir para
alguns milhares e as editoras começaram
a entrar em contato comigo
elas queriam enviar livros estão todos
chegava uma caixa de livros em casa eu
conheci um lançamento para conhecer um
autor novo até mesmo o trabalho dessas
editoras também foi nessa parte
eu tive que contar com os pais estão
achando que eu era louco de fazer
compras na internet
mas aí depois não tenho um amigo meu
descobriu no fim a reação dele foi tão
legal que resolveu bloquear todo mundo e
talvez reconhecer que de fato teria
virado um destes perfis literários
eu tinha virado um do plano eu tinha
virado buxer e hoje depois de mais de
quase dois anos na verdade do books e eu
fico muito feliz de saber que eu tenho
mais de 90 mil pessoas compartilhando
comigo as experiências literárias
isso mostra que a maioria do que as
pessoas pensam o falo daquele
estereótipo de que o brasileiro não quer
ler que tem muita gente sempre quer
dizer é que às vezes não sabe por onde
começar ou pessoas que perderam o hábito
da leitura seja curta terem filhos
escola faculdade pós graduação e não tem
mais tempo e agora está encontrando nas
próprias redes sociais que costumam ser
um lugar que afastam as pessoas da
leitura estão retomando esse hábito
uma pergunta que sempre fazem é que a
leitura traz de bom além lógico de
melhorar minha escrita em ajudar no
trabalho me trazer mais conhecimento
iniciais a capacidade de enxergar e me
colocar no lugar do outro
por meio dela eu consigo enxergar
problemas em chegar a situações a partir
da perspectiva do outro seja quando eu
li um livro de uma escritora nascida na
somália sofreu mutilação genital ainda
quando criança seja quando leio um livro
de relatos de mulheres que lutaram e
foram para o front da segunda guerra
mundial e sofreram a vida inteira pelo
trauma de ter matado alguém
ou essas atrocidades que vivenciaram ou
seja quando eu leio um livro de uma
criança e passou a infância toda
sofrendo
a falta de estrutura familiar em todas
as situações
me coloco na posição do outro eu passei
a compreender ea respeitar mais o outro
pelas suas diferenças e pelo que ele é e
agora dizem estar se perguntando tá bom
mas então como ler mais a resposta não é
mais a resposta nem sempre leitura é um
hábito diário traz de série do seu dia a
dia e quando falo hábito diário
não tô falando tele 200 300 páginas por
dia eu não consigo por exemplo se vocês
conseguirem ótimo eu tenho inveja de
gostei mas então quando fala fala todo
dia lê dez páginas se eu chego em casa o
vôlei três páginas eu vou te dizer
naquele dia
com isso o seu ritmo de leitura aumenta
muito e não vai mais perder o fio da
meada das histórias que você está lendo
e não vai mesmo abandonar livro e além
disso além dessa mudança pessoal eu
insisto muito na importância a gente
disseminar a leitura diz que mudou
pessoalmente muda com o outro pergunta o
seu amigo faço de leitura pergunta pra
ele com o último livro que leu com
partir de ser ministro ou tenha
credíveis que está encostado na sua
estante doe faça a informação circular
empreste o livro então quando a gente
fala sobre ler mais
a gente tem que pensar que em dois bons
quer deles leitura um hábito diário
vamos fazer uma mudança com nós mesmos
em segundo lugar vamos incentivar os
outros vamos levar a literatura o
assunto por dia a dia
o incentivo da leitura pode e deve sim
partir de cada um de nós como dizia
mário quintana livro como léo mundo
quem manda é o mundo são as pessoas e os
livros só mudam as pessoas
obrigado